I'm sitting here with Andy Brown, who's
one of the people who heads up a lot of
our education initiatives
here at Udacity.
And in fact, not long ago, Andy was kind
of lead on transitioning a lot of what
we do at Udacity to a more project-based
approach, to have students completing
projects as part of their experience and
learning different skills.
So, thank you so much for
talking to me today,
Andy, about project-based learning.
>> Yeah, thanks for doing this.
>> So the first thing I want to ask, and
I think this comes up a lot when we're
dealing with teachers who want to
do a project-based approach, but
are very stretched for resources.
Is that project-based learning,
at least in my opinion,
is much more difficult to implement
in a classroom than some traditional
instruction of just lecturing or
giving material straight away.
Is it worth the extra effort,
and if so why?
>> Yes, it's absolutely worth
doing project-based learning.
And now that there's all sorts of free
resources online there's a lot of free
time, potentially, for instructors to be
spending their time coming up with and
helping their students as they go
through these project activities.
There's lots of great explanations, lots
of great sort of static resources out
there that, they're going to solve a lot
of the sort of, what am I going to say?
How am I going to explain this topic?
And, in fact to me that's not
the interesting part of the teaching.
The interesting part of the teaching
is how am I going to shepherd
this person along as their
brain transforms, and
that's best done through
an authentic project.
So, yes it's totally worth it.
It is hard.
>> But it's getting easier.
>> Yeah.
>> This is your job if
you've signed up to it.
>> Exactly, I think I've always had
the idea that you just referred to of
basically building a course around
all these awesome free materials that
are available online.
Because there's so much out there
that wasn't out there before, and
that led to this class which is
an entire class based largely around
the materials that
are already free online.
Instead of trying to reinvent the wheel
and represent things that have
already been presented very well,
let's just see if we can leverage it and
spend our time on kind of the more
student-focused, mentoring and feedback.
Speaking of feedback, so
one thing that's very difficult I think
in project-based learning is assessment.
When, you know, I have a bunch
of students who all do the same
math problem.
I know what the correct answer is.
I know what the steps are.
And, it's very easy for me to go through
and say, you screwed up step two,
you screwed up step four.
>> But so what.
What do you know when you've done that?
>> Yeah, that's true.
But yeah assessment in projects
is more difficult, isn't it?
It's a little more open ended.
>> It is but it's getting more towards
what you actually want to be measuring.
So yes it's very easy to measure my,
some students ability to factor
ten polynomials correctly.
It's just not a very
interesting measurement.
Every now and then you'll find things
that can be assessed that way.
Or really it's very important to know
these facts before you can move on.
But I'm guessing that if you
as an educator ask yourself,
what do I really want?
How do I want to change my students with
this learning experience I'm crafting?
You'll find it's really hard to
phrase that in terms of some
multiple choice questions or
anything like that.
And this is especially
a danger when you're doing
online project based learning.
Because multiple choice questions are by
far the easiest things to do online.
Right, wrong, tally up a score.
You have a little green progress bar and
it works.
But that experience just is never
going to be even close to what you can
get if you try to do
the project based learning.
>> Yeah, exactly.
And I think that we have, many of
our courses, not our courses, but
courses that are currently
available online, or
built around these
multiple choice tests.
But you have exactly that,
where often times they have
repeatability built into them.
Which is great,
because you learn from your failures.
You get problems wrong,
you move forward and learn.
But when you have only a small
set of possible answers,
what you're really learning is that
c isn't the answer to that question.
You're not learning the deeper
understanding of what's going on there.
But for a teacher who has dealing with,
for example in our class,
possibly a 100 different projects,
all of which need feedback.
Are there any strategies
to how to give feedback in
such a way that students can
actually improve on it while doing
the project as opposed to just finding
out at the end that they already failed.
>> Yeah, if you can bake feedback into
the nature of the project itself.
So an example for building an HTML,
a webpage let's say.
If you don't know anything
about programming, sorry!
If you're building a webpage and I say
build a webpage that looks like this and
I give you a little image
that looks like a webpage.
The feedback is pretty natural,
the feedback is like well it
doesn't look like that anymore,
you don't need the instructor to come
tell you that, the student knows it.
And then if you can set up systems
of feedback within students,
you'd be amazed the things
that can happen when you
do the terrifying thing of
stepping back as an instructor and
just letting your students screw up and
sort of screw up together.
That can be a really amazing
learning experience.
There has to be some constraints placed
on that, but you can do it really well.
So, yeah, if you find yourself staying
up until 4 AM, frantically grading
100 projects, it's probably not ideal,
and you're probably killing yourself.
[LAUGH] So, you're probably not giving
the best feedback to your students that
you could,
because nobody could do that And
there's probably a more creative
solution that will be just as good.
>> Yeah, it sounds like there are a lot
of ways that we can go about that,
like giving exemplars that
a student can, on their own,
compare their assignment
to some exemplar.
And see where it's different and
where it's similar, maybe
building in some automated assessment
through some artificial intelligence.
Not just that question was wrong, but
something a little bit deeper
about the real nature of learning.
And then let the peers
give them feedback on it.
I think we often learn best from people
who are going through the same struggles
that we're going through.
But you mentioned doing this
in the context of web design.
I think you're exactly right that we
often talk about project based learning,
the context of computer science
because professionally,
what we do in computer
science is mostly projects.
What about some other
fields like accounting or
nursing or,
can't think of another field.
But other fields where,
it's not necessarily a project
based on what you actually do.
Can project based
learning be used there?
Or is there something that can be done
that kind of perpetuates the same
philosophical underpinnings
of project based learning.
>> I think those fields are still
project based, actually.
I think.
I think we've overloaded this word,
project.
In computer programming, project can be
what you call the thing you're working
on on the side,
this cool webpage you're building.
In project-based learning, the word
project means something very specific.
It means an authentic task,
an extended task, so
it won't be completed in a single day.
It's sort of loosely defined,
so there's room for creativity.
And the nurse who is monitoring my
blood glucose levels, that's a project.
The accountant who's doing my taxes,
if anyone who wants to do project-based
learning and do my taxes,
that'd be good.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But that's a project, right?
That's an authentic thing.
Like balancing the books on this
company, that's an authentic thing.
So I think projects are there,
if you can find them.
>> Yeah.
>> And if they're not,
a computer's probably
doing that job already.
>> That's true.
That makes a lot of sense that we,
you know, in pure sense we talk about
projects because it's something where
I create the idea, I implement it,
I execute it and I deliver it.
But you're exactly right,
a project can be anything on going.
It's got some investment in it,
but doesn't necessarily have to be
completely open to whatever
the student want's to specify.
So, this is an educational technology
class and so we're really looking for
the ways that we can use
technology to enhance education.
Maybe the learning process or
maybe education as a broader community.
So specifically on the technology front,
are there things that technology let's
us do in project based learning
that are difficult to do in person?
>> Let me start by saying the things
that technology tempts us to do
that we would never do in person.
And that's the things like
the radio button quizzes.
The sort of like, oh, I know how to do a
project, and I'm going to have 10 check
box quizzes that I'll ask
about how much would you
put in this box of my tax return if
you're doing the account in the example.
That's not authentic.
Nobody thinks it's authentic.
It's not fun.
It's not a good product base learning.
It's a very, like,
superficial substitute.
And, it's really tempting to do because
it's so much easier than anything else.
The things that the Internet give you.
The Internet gives you scale and
it gives you access, so.
I mean it gives you the chance to
have people from across the country,
across the world,
working together on a task at any hour.
That's pretty cool.
>> Yeah.
>> But, it's a lot of work to set up,
and there's a lot of
ways it can go wrong.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So, [LAUGH] I mean,
there's tradeoffs for sure, but still,
it's a better way of learning,
if you can find a way to make it work.
>> Yeah.
Makes sense, and
I think that technology
gives us a lot of ways to,
exactly what you're saying,
make it a little bit more open.
That it's not necessarily something that
has to happen within the confines of
the one hour lecture that we have set
aside for this class three days a week.
It's something that can happen
at three o'clock in the morning
when I just happen to be online and
a student asks a question.
Or you know there's
a project to review and
I can watch their progress live which I
really have difficulty doing in person.
At Georgia Tech we actually have some
classes that have tried to implement
that approach.
Where students will come to a lab and
there's no lectures or anything
like that, but there is set-aside class
time that they're expected to be there.
And the idea is sit there,
work on your project, and someone will
be in the room to give you feedback.
But that's a pretty big pragmatic
constraint of they have nine hours
a week where they're required to be
in the studio working on a project.
During that time.
And now we also have a person who
has to be there during that time,
whereas the Internet allows us to do
that a little bit more asynchronously.
Because it makes
the classroom unlocked 24/7.
So do you have any final thoughts for
our students who are both engaging in
project-based learning in this class,
and may also be trying to develop tools
that facilitate project-based learning?
>> Yeah well, if you're going through
this class, which is itself an example
of project-based learning, reflect
on what's going well and what's not.
There's learning to
be done just in that.
When you go on to try
to do project-based
learning in your own classroom.
It's hard.
You're not going to get
it right to begin with.
The bad version will still probably
be better than if you hadn't tried,
but it's going to feel chaotic and
sort of out of control really,
out of your control.
And that's sort of the nature of
project-based learning, is the student's
gain more autonomy, which is
a lot of the reason why we do it.
So stay reflective.
Next year will be better.
And the next year will
be better than that.
And this is how we improve at our craft.
>> This is how I justify what I said
at the beginning of this course.
Which is that there are some things
that we'll do in this course that will
fail miserably.
See now I have an expert
saying that's okay.
So.
Thank you so much for
talking with us today, Andy,
and for your perspective.
And thank you all.